Ukraine has launched what appears to be
the biggest wave of airstrikes into
Russia since the start of the war Moscow
says six regions have been hit by drone
attacks overnight the targets include an
airport where military planes were based
no casualties have been reported Russia
has hit back with strikes on the
Ukrainian Capital Kiev
here's the six regions in Russia that
ukrainians were able to hit peskov
region near the Estonian border suffered
the most damage and then a large fire
broke out at an airport other regions
reported minimal damage with most drones
shot down Russia's attack on key killed
at least two people let's go to dorso
Jabari Who's Live For Us in Saint
Petersburg dorsal what is Russia saying
about this attack
well we got an update from officials
here the main one the main attack that
took place in pascalf region which is
about 300 kilometers Southwest of St
Petersburg and it's about 200 kilometers
from the border with NATO member Estonia
according to officials there were four
military transport planes that were
damaged in that attack and there was
some damage as well to the runway of the
airport which continues to remain closed
according to the local governor of the
Scott region we also understand that
attacks took place in Moscow region
forcing officials to close down all the
four major airports in the capital
overnight for a brief period of time
where a number of flights were diverted
but they've since reopened and we also
just heard from the foreign Ministry
spokesperson Maria zaharaba who said the
following she said Ukraine's attempt to
attack Russia is a dead end basically
for the Ukrainian authorities and the
agony of the Kiev regime and the stupid
hatred anger and the absence of any
prospects in their own development has
led to this terrorist act the feeling
here is that this is one of the most
Brazen attacks on Russian territory
since the start of the so-called special
military operation which began in
February of 2022 we are waiting to get a
full briefing from the Russian defense
Ministry in the coming hours about those
attacks that the ukrainians are claiming
Russia carried out overnight
there for us in the Saint Petersburg
let's go to Rob McBride who's in key for
us Rob have the ukrainians actually
admitted responsibility for these
attacks on Russia overnight
yeah I mean as always the Ukrainian
authorities never comment directly on
these attacks or which they describe uh
including this one as merely accidents
happening on Russian territory but the
administration here including Vladimir
zelenski the president have said that
Russian air bases do present legitimate
targets and it does uh follow a pattern
now as a surge an uptick in attacks on
Russian air bases not only air bases in
occupied Crimea but also in in Russia
itself we saw just over a week ago there
was an attack again in the far Northwest
of Russia and air base near Saint
Petersburg where according to images
circulated uh on on social media
reportedly a long-range supersonic
bomber one of Russia's latest was either
damaged or completely destroyed on the
ground then just over the weekend there
was another attack on an air base close
to Kursk which is just over 100
kilometers north of the Ukrainian border
inside Russia when again it does appear
as though drones struck that air base
and according to the ukrainians five
Russian Jets were badly damaged or
destroyed on the ground according to pro
pro Kremlin bloggers it was an
ineffectual
um attack but you are seeing this
increase in attacks on uh Russian air
bases uh the attack on the cursed Air
Base could well have been launched from
drones launched from inside Ukraine but
these attacks in the far north west of
Russia it does make it appear as though
it's unlikely it seems as though a drone
could get for that far from Ukrainian
territory all the way across Russian
territory to to strike these targets
there is the possibility that these
could have been launched by uh smaller
drones by groups inside Russia itself
okay thank you for that Rob McBride
there for us in Kiev